hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the latest highest end windows phone
device from nokia mostly because of the
camera that's a lot of the reason why
anyone is even talking about this phone
or considering it at all but there's a
lot more to a phone than just the camera
but we're going to take a look at
everything about this latest device this
is the full review of the nokia lumia
1020. now we all know the nokia lumia
series is a family of windows phone
devices and that seems to be their
defining feature this is the highest end
one of the bunch and to be honest it's
pretty similar to the rest of the nokia
windows phones at first glance it has
that big body it's pretty thick bright
colors rounded corners but a squared off
top and bottom and it's got that button
layout at the bottom that all the rest
of the windows phone devices also have
but it's pretty amazingly well built
actually with no seams on the back or
any of the sides it's basically a single
block slab design with a display on the
front and everything is milled from that
single block so the buttons the volume
rocker the milled speakers on the bottom
everything is part of that single block
design it's also a very big phone like
bigger than the moto x in every way
bigger and wider than the galaxy s4
thicker than the galaxy s4 heavier than
the galaxy s4 but of course we all
already expected that out of a nokia
windows phone but holding it in the hand
it actually feels pretty great it has a
well-balanced heft to it and its mass
has 158 grams so you really feel like
you're holding a solid device in your
hand when you're using it which is nice
and of course you're bound to notice
when you're using it that when you turn
it around to the back that is where
you'll find the massive hump where the
imaging hardware resides so that's your
41 megapixel pureview sensor the carl
zeiss glass and the xenon flash and the
focus is his light all top-notch optics
but we'll get to that in just a second
the main disrupter here is that the
camera hump is so big that it affects
the rest of using the phone sometimes i
wasn't quite sure where to put my
fingers on the back of the phone while
using it and more importantly it never
sits flat on any table so if you're
someone who likes to text while their
phone is lying on a desk or something
you can count out that sort of activity
on this lumia inside it's also very
similar to other nokia windows phones
it's rocking a 1.5 gigahertz dual core
snapdragon s4 chip a 2 gigabytes of ram
and 32 gigabytes of internal storage and
a 2 000 milliamp hour battery but we all
know that windows phones don't really
need insane specs to handle everything
they do really well and for my everyday
usage i found this to be true with this
phone too this one performs really well
for a heavy user like me it handles
everyday tasks really smoothly opens and
closes apps quickly scrolling as nice as
ever of course on windows phone and
multitasking is a breeze thanks to those
two gigs of ram now one thing i noticed
about web browsing in internet explorer
here was that it's definitely smooth but
at the expense of a lot of
checkerboarding and blank spaces when
zooming in and out or scrolling quickly
kind of reminds me of the older phones
that did that like the lg voyager where
once you zoom in on text you have to
wait for it to re-render anyway you can
pull off some gaming on this phone too
now obviously this is windows phone so
there aren't exactly a ton of games to
choose from but with the few games i was
able to try it worked smoothly and
quickly without a hitch and i got great
frame rates of course and that's the way
it should be right so so far so good
next on to the display so see there
aren't that many high-end resolution
windows phone 8 devices and this one is
no exception really it's a 4.5 inch 1280
by 768 display a lot of people are
thinking wait a second wow uh a device
that's bigger and thicker and wider than
the galaxy s4 has a smaller display than
the moto x uh yeah when you take a
closer look at it you'll realize just
how much bezel we're working with here
on this device and then there's the
resolution which gives it a pixel
density of 334 pixels per inch which is
not bad but now there is something else
worth noting about the windows phone ui
specifically some apps like for example
the calendar have one pixel wide
elements of it which allows you to
literally see the entire width of a
pixel and when you start to look at it
closely you'll immediately start seeing
individual pixels and that's something i
just couldn't wrap my head around the
fact that the highest end windows phone
device you can buy right now you can see
pixels on the display it's disappointing
considering i've seen much much better
displays in much less expensive devices
everything else about the display though
is really not that bad it has great
color reproduction first of all good
viewing angles too and since it's an
amoled display the contrast ratio is
great and whenever you have a black
background or the black elements of the
display those pixels are not being lit
at all which makes them look pure black
and also makes for a great battery life
since they don't have to light those
pixels and this phone lasted a full day
which is great on battery but enough
about the rest of the phone i know what
you're here for that camera this has a
41 megapixel camera on the back
so is it any good well the short answer
is yes it's the best camera on any
smartphone right now like any phone
period so there's that but it's also one
of those cameras that just really makes
you want to get out and take pictures of
everything because you know the picture
is just going to turn out well every
single time now there are a number of
things to address about the picture
taking experience before the image
quality because everyone seems to want
to focus on the image quality first of
all this is a pretty wide-angle lens on
the back on purpose second this is a
real xenon flash so it uses a focus
assist light and then actually fires a
flash like a real digital camera instead
of the typical smartphone led light
third this phone comes with a
specialized nokia pro cam app so yes you
could use the stock windows phone camera
app but that doesn't make much sense it
doesn't take advantage of it so the pro
cam app is included here to take
advantage of all those pixels next the
camera ui here is a really smart one you
can leave it in full auto if you want
and it pretty much always takes great
pictures in full auto or you can use the
controls to change up the settings one
by one so you can manually adjust
exposure compensation the shutter speed
the iso the focus or the white balance
and of course you can turn flash on and
off so basically all these controls are
up at the touch of a finger up at the
top they're very out of the way so you
can still see your image so let's say
you're outdoors and you want to have a
really fast shutter speed to freeze
action you can basically take the
shutter speed off auto and pick the
shutter speed that you want make it nice
and fast and it basically goes into
shutter priority mode everything else
stays automatic and you can see the iso
automatically adjusting as you move
around it'll turn red to let you know
when you've gotten a bit too high but
basically you want to avoid that and
again like i said this viewfinder is
super smart it'll automatically adjust
all the other things about the image to
make it work with that shutter speed and
you can snap your picture and freeze the
image and one more thing this lens has
real optical image stabilization so you
can get a sharper image during longer
shutter times or when video recording
all that is stabilized last thing you
need to know is that in the time between
shots there's a really big delay here uh
and unfortunately there's also no burst
mode and there's no built-in hdr
processing so it may feel a little bit
slow but without any further ado i took
a ton of pictures while using the lumia
as my daily driver so here are some of
the most impressive pictures i took with
it over the past two weeks check these
out
all right so the main takeaway here from
the images that i took was that the
biggest strength here was the sharpness
thanks to all those pixels and the
optical image stabilization and the
biggest weakness i think was color i
took a lot of these pictures in full
auto with auto white balance and the
color accuracy was really hit or miss
and sometimes it was way wrong not even
even close and it was even more apparent
in the video i took so you can see this
video right here from the train where
the colors are basically shifted and not
at all very lifelike now this nokia pro
cam app also has a few more tricks up
its sleeve first of all for the photos
it takes a 38 megapixel full resolution
shot and also at the same time saves a 5
megapixel over sampled image which was
much smaller in file size and that's
what you can use to share to twitter
instagram etc wherever windows fun will
let you share and it actually felt like
a lot of these five megapixel over
sampled shots were a bit sharper than
the full res ones another trick it has
up its sleeve is to crop and reframe
your shots after the fact and this is
what nokia is advertising everywhere so
since it's a 38 megapixel shot and a
wide angle lens you can basically crop
and reframe the shot exactly the way you
want it and resave it and keep tons of
detail this gives you a lot more
flexibility when taking pictures of
landmarks and landscapes groups of
people animals moving objects etc it's
really great very useful so it is indeed
a great camera experience of course
again it is almost always going to take
amazing pictures on the first try in
full auto mode my big problem what i
would say is that it's a 41 megapixel
sensor with a 720p viewfinder so there's
tons of line skipping and more and stuff
and sometimes pictures really don't look
that great when you're taking it on the
phone but then you go and check it on
the computer and it looks amazing so at
the end of the day you have to be the
one to decide if you want the best
camera and a phone so badly that you're
willing to switch to windows phone and
all of its quirks which there are a lot
of and as a person who uses a lot of
google services this is a tough sell
because of course microsoft and google
are not exactly friends at this point
and there's plenty missing from windows
phone that i would love to have and you
got to decide if you're willing to
switch to windows phone and go all out
just to get this incredible camera or if
you're just gonna wait and stick to the
already really great cameras and a lot
of the other phones with different
operating systems if i was already a
windows phone person i would be all over
this phone this is the phone to get if
you want windows phone there's pretty
much no other choice right now they're
all already pretty big phones so you
might as well just go with the slightly
larger one and get a 41 megapixel sensor
that delivers incredible optical image
quality either way there is pretty much
nothing else to say this is a great
device if you guys are liking uh
especially the color choices there's a
gray a white a black and a yellow and i
of course went with yellow because that
seems pretty sweet
but otherwise that's been it thank you
for watching if you enjoyed this video
feel free to give a thumbs up below and
there's also a subscribe button below if
you want to get more of the videos i
upload like this thank you for watching
and i'll talk to you guys very soon in
the next video peace
you